[Music]
it is true that transgender youth gender
diverse youth youth who don't
necessarily transition but whose gender
expression is diverse or considered
non-conforming more fluid are at higher
risk of verbal harassment and even
physical bullying within a school
context that's been consistently
demonstrated in surveys over the last 10
to 15 years
so what I'd say to trans youth who are
experiencing bullying is that it's
absolutely important that you talk to an
adult in your life about what's
happening that you don't need to
navigate harassment or bullying by
yourself
in fact it's critical to reach out and
let someone safe in your life another
adult know what's happening and that you
can identify who that safe person is
whether it's a teacher a school
counselor a school social worker a
parent an extended family member but
it's important to let someone know
what's happening because you have a
right to be able to go to school and be
safe and be free from the experience of
bullying what the research is telling us
in the last 10 years is that family
acceptance a young person's a teenager's
experience of being accepted by their
families is the critical mediating
variable in queer young adult risk
factors so teenagers queer teenagers
lesbian gay bi trans teenagers growing
up in families they experience as
rejecting are eight and a half times
more likely to have attempted suicide by
the time they're 21 to 24 and there are
three and a half times more likely to be
at risk of HIV to be using drugs and
alcohol in an addictive way or
problematic way much higher rates of
anxiety and depression and that by
contrast those risks are much lower for
adolescents growing up in families that
they experience as accepting the
important piece about that for parents
is the degree to which we can have an
impact in lowering the risk factors that
trans youth already face in a world
that sometimes is still hostile or
discriminatory and that even in the face
of external discrimination or harassment
by peers or other adults or
discriminatory laws family acceptance
shows up as the critical mediating
variable for young adult risks among
trans youth so one best practice is to
recognize that every one of us as a
human being has a right to define who we
are and that gender identity is not
necessarily about our body parts but
it's about our own understanding of who
we are as male or female both or neither
it's what's in our brains it's what we
know to be true about ourselves and so
if we begin with that understanding and
an acknowledgement that every human
being deserves to be acknowledged and
respected for who they know themselves
to be that sets a real foundation in
working with trans youth that each trans
young person like any other young person
deserves to be acknowledged and treated
with respect for who they are that means
things like using a young person's
affirmed name and pronouns regardless of
whether or not that matches your
understanding or knowledge of that young
person but if I say my pronouns are male
and my name is Elijah then part of
respect it is respecting my
understanding of myself from a treatment
perspective that means what's been
emerging as best practices in the last
10 years is an understanding of gender
expression within young children and
adolescence as gender diversity and not
gender variance or gender nonconformity
and that all children experiment with
gender expression that children can have
diverse and different ways of expressing
their gender young boys might like to
play house young girls might like to
play with trucks and that that's simply
gender diversity and while it may not be
the norm to have a boy who's has
feminine gender interests it is within
the realm of normal and that there's
nothing inherently abnormal or
pathological it's simply gender
diversity and may or may not mean
that that young child grows up to
identify as trans I think part of the
work for parents and many of us who are
parenting today grew up in a world that
did see gender and sex or gender
identity and biological sex as
synonymous and we've all grown up in
worlds where there are cultural norms
about how men are supposed to act or
look and how women are supposed to act
or look but part of what's important is
realizing that those cultural norms vary
over time and they vary from one culture
to another that there's not necessarily
anything inherently right or wrong about
certain ways that men might express
themselves or women might express
themselves in the world one example is
that you know in white Western culture
most cisgender men are not allowed to be
very physically affectionate or
expressive but if you travel in Latin
countries Mediterranean countries
cisgender straight men often much more
physically expressive greeting each
other with a kiss walking arm-in-arm
and that's considered normative
masculine behavior there so part of the
takeaway for parents is really
questioning those norms that we've grown
up with and recognizing that our
children may land anywhere in terms of
their gender expression and that
correcting that expression or enforcing
strict gender norms means children grow
up with an increasing sense of shame
about who they are so if a ten-year-old
boy twelve-year-old boy is frequently
told don't throw like that that's how
girls throw don't be a sissy don't walk
like that only girls walk like that that
10 to 12 year old boy begins to move
into adolescence and adulthood feeling
like there's something wrong with who he
is and having a sense of internalized
shame about himself that puts him at
risk in terms of mental health and
substance use so historically the
understanding of gender nonconformity or
gender expression that's outside the
of what would be considered
stereotypically acceptable for a man or
a woman within the culture has been
defined in the Western world largely by
the psychiatry profession and any kind
of gender expression that was not
normatively masculine for men or
normatively feminine for women was
considered abnormal and pathologized
historically so from that model children
young five-year-old boy who has feminine
gender interests likes to play with
dolls likes the color pink would it
would have been treated historically in
a manner that was designed to shut down
those feminine gender interests and
redirect him into solely what are
considered socially acceptable masculine
interests like trucks and cars and blue
so historically gender diversity gender
expression outside the norms considered
non-conforming and abnormal so if we
think about that shifting in some ways
we can think about the homosexuality
being removed from the DSM in 1973 and
ironically enough in 1980 gender
identity disorder went into the DSM and
from many perspectives there's some
thought that gender identity disorder
went into the DSM in 1980 as a way to
continue to monitor particularly what
might be emerging gay male identity or
men with feminine gender interests from
growing up to become gay men so young
boys with feminine gender interests
now diagnosed with gender identity
disorder still considered an abnormality
the result of inappropriate parenting
the result of incomplete gender
development from a Freudian perspective
but now gender identity as a psychiatric
diagnosis that any trans person has to
receive in order to be allowed to
medically transition as we move from
1980 on part of what we see is
transgender people in the society
becoming more and more visible more and
more vocal about their stories their
narratives
their life experiences and with that
comes a greater understanding that
gender and sex are not nearly as binary
as we thought they were that in addition
to the biological sexes of male and
female one in two thousand infants are
born with what's called an intersex
condition which means the doctor can't
easily assign them in one of those two
boxes at Birth based on genitalia or
chromosomal makeup and so even
biological sex which we think of as
those two boxes male or female is more
diverse and certainly our understandings
of gender identity and gender expression
shifting to be much more of a continuum
from very very masculine or male
identified all the way across that
continuum to more traditionally feminine
in gender expression or female
identified in every point in between
[Music]